la escritora ensayista directora de cine
francesa carole y forest se encuentra en
argentina para hablar de su libro
generación ofendida de la policía de la
cultura a la policía del pensamiento en
la feria del libro de buenos aires donde
también participará de un encuentro
internacional el llamado pensar el
futuro gracias por acompañarnos en
france 24 en español gracias
tras dos años de pandemia en el mundo
que puso un parante a proyectos y
habidas una guerra ahora en ucrania que
además está trastocando las relaciones
globales y pensando en la charla que van
a dar esta conferencia que se va a dar
en la feria del libro de buenos aires
que nos espera en el futuro
es que solo se puede mejorar pero es
verdad que pensábamos ser una generación
a salvo sin embargo nos damos cuenta de
que siempre hay grandes desafíos y
desafíos donde si no pensamos bien en el
mundo si no nombramos bien las cosas tal
como albert camus le gustaba decirlo
podemos añadir desgracias al mundo
entonces una de las batallas que pueden
dar los ensayistas es por lo menos
intentar nombrar bien las cosas ahora
bien esto es algo que ocurre sobre todo
en ámbitos universitarios y de la alta
cultura a veces si se quiere
no es un problema de élites en
definitiva o si no lo es como termina
premiando al resto de la sociedad la
mayoría de las personas que viven en
este mundo no paran o forman parte de
estos grupos entonces entonces ahora
como los puede llegar a afectar o tal
vez no no seamos claros la manera muy
excesivas tal vez un poco sectaria e
identitaria con la cual evoluciona hoy
en día cierto antirracismo concierne a
las élites concierne a la juventud
dorada más bien privilegiada de las
universidades más importantes el
problema es que esa es la élite del día
de mañana si las clases populares la
juventud de las clases populares escucha
esos discursos excesivos como por
ejemplo que los más oprimidos son los
que son víctimas de micro agresiones así
se olvida que hay clases populares que
sufren de no poder comer a fin de mes
nos vamos a encontrar con un mundo
polarizado
polarizado entre una juventud elitista
que es extremadamente walk es decir
extremadamente despierta pero
esencialmente alimentada por los
contragolpes del sexismo de la homofobia
y del racismo y por el otro lado una
juventud popular blanca que al ser tan
exasperada por esos discursos
desconectados de lo real y completamente
al límite del absurdo va a abrazar a los
supremacistas entonces la meta es
justamente de volver a elaborar una
conversación pública y de despolarizar
volviendo a poner las cosas en una buena
escala a que pertenece a una micro
ofensa
que pertenece a una gran desigualdad el
rol de los políticos consiste en
combatir las grandes desigualdades del
rol del debate consiste en mejorar
nuestra conversación pública para evitar
las micro ofensas entre que escribió el
libro y el momento actual en el que
vivimos pasaron un par de años quiero
saber si en ese periodo aparecieron
cosas nuevas o ideas nuevas que
repensando los temas del libro la llevan
a pensar que tal vez le quedaron cosas
por decir tal vez material para un nuevo
libro material
primero cuando uno termina un libro
siempre está viendo nacer el siguiente
cuando salió el libro en francia y fue
verdaderamente traducido en numerosos
países europeos al principio me decían
que eran fenómenos muy estadounidenses
hoy en día en algunos meses nomás la
gente se dio cuenta de que no de que son
fenómenos que conciernen todas las
democracias posmodernas que estamos
todos involucrados lo que cambió con la
publicación del libro fue que fui yo una
de las primeras en alertar en francia
sobre estas cuestiones lo quería hacer
justamente para que la crítica de esos
excesos no viniera del extrema derecha
sino de la izquierda de alguien
feminista anti racista que mira de
frente esas derivas y que protege lo
esencial de esos valores sin embargo hoy
en día después de la campaña y electoral
por supuesto que el extrema derecha
intentó instrumentalizar esos excesos
para manchar y descalificar la izquierda
anti racista o feminista en su conjunto
entonces estoy bastante feliz de haber
dado la alerta antes de esta campaña
electoral para poder hacer exactamente
lo que quería
decir no hace falta votar a la extrema
derecha si ustedes están hartos de estos
excesos hay personas a favor de la
igualdad que también son conscientes de
ello que buscan otro camino una manera
de luchar para la igualdad sin pisar las
libertades sin caer en los excesos y
pienso que es algo necesario si no
queremos dejarle a la extrema derecha la
bandera de las libertades la crítica del
gou kismer y al fin y al cabo una
alfombra roja
cada uno y forrest muchas gracias muchas
gracias a ustedes muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 en español los
invitamos a seguir con nuestra
programación